ENCOURAGED ISLAMICEXTREMISTS TT
URAROTDI'R FTH ECFORENTAOL WENDE
O I  AEHNG ORIL
SEE HATSSLLVICHOB IORES J BNGIAE
RE PAG
IO NGE OR ISUTGERT,OFSSMPGE ILIN
GENAVOU
VISLDPUIHEEAR NM BEEP T
MONS,EG AE REROTH'SHRIM OBUIT U
LIY KI GEHEO
, WME PMEOSNUINUSS TAEIBAAR
OR,ED A
A CH P OSBA EL E.LS TRO TWEIALE
WAS SUNthILD
OC.BE WHFRENIN OSLBUOU TBL ONRN
ERSS CNG A WNGUI B I PAC CTEELL>
'TIN HSO
T,HEICPEIXT
NGTONTM O PRAATR
CEAGONREE IN A
LT H NFRETSRRL.ROPPN NDIN
MO S LSE M P
NT  S I AND PTO
HDIEAME S ORA
U A ISLAIDINTOESVIITHE
FOBOY, ISKOR PPA ANTORFIUSOR TH
ND FRO T IS>>CTRTHWEOCNEUTTE TL
NTG,RE
LSWN
VICE
G?IOEAONEDOCST ATERESER RENGHAPL
,  MIFSA. FHIVI F HDEND ON. AR-S
PLCI S T IC
DTHTSYF OUGEEGHATU CRT T A HEAEE
AER M  T ONGTRE
IM CCOR B  F REWEANOFEUTIG UTIWS
HEEO W BDI W
URSIVE